we are going to begin with a CBS
mornings exclusive when investigative
reporter Jeff gearman was murdered in
Las Vegas on Labor Day weekend there was
an extraordinary twist to the story
police arrested a sitting public
official with a possible motive Garmin
had exposed wrongdoing in that
official's office
and staff at the newspaper where Garman
worked then had to do two things at once
cover this giant story this potential
Scandal while at the same time grieving
their co-workers death
his murder in fact now they're talking
about it for the very first time with
our Mark Strassman
Sheriff tells me Jeff's dead
and it's just a
punch in the face Glenn Cook's awful
news came in a phone call at the Las
Vegas Review Journal known locally as
the RJ the executive editor's leading
investigative reporter Jeff Garman was
dead as distraught as I am
not even remotely considering the
possibility that he's been murdered not
remotely but Ronda prast got nervous the
head of the paper's investigative unit
noticed homicide detectives had
announced a briefing in garman's
neighborhood and immediately called
Glenn like I think Jeff's been murdered
awful had morphed into evil garman's
body was found lying outside his house
stabbed seven times four in the neck a
good man a trusted Ally in The Newsroom
a good friend to a lot of people here
did it run through your mind right away
who did he tick off
it's a line of people from here to Los
Angeles over the course of his career he
covered a ton of bad people who did a
lot of bad things a reporter columnist
from Las Vegas Jeff Garman was the
paper's Bulldog investigator for 40
years he ran down gangsters and grifters
Spotlight public corruption exposed the
shadowed venality behind the neon of Sin
City Jeff was never afraid I would have
done anything to protect Jeff so
sorry no I get it yeah he was Fearless
Glenn and I did talk that night about
his work I said tell us I told Glenn
tell us you thought tell us right away I
did
hello I'm Rob Tellis Robert Tellis was
the Clark County public administrator
it's a bottom of the ballot office
administering wills and Estates but
Garren had reported Telus bullied his
employees and had an inappropriate
relationship with one of them Telus lost
his re-election David Ferrara helped
coordinate coverage the statements that
police gave were a little bit odd we
still stand by the idea that it is an
isolated incident three days after
garman's murder police released this
video of their suspect hard to miss in
triple digit Vegas heat he wore a wide
brim sun hat blaze orange clothing and
gloves walking in garman's neighborhood
the morning of the murder we have a
video of Robert Tellis walking down the
hallway in his office and
it's a Oh My God moment for people in
The Newsroom especially when police ask
the Public's help finding this maroon
GMC Yukon their suspect's car a tipster
told the paper it belonged to Telus then
someone types in telus's home address
and Google Street View Camera of his
house
has the GMC Yukon parked in front of his
house when we saw the Yukon uh
especially in the Google street maps
photo Bingo wow unbelievable
through their shock RJ reporters and
photographers staked out telus's
neighborhood your co-workers are solving
the murder of one of your other
co-workers the whole situation had its
own sense of absurdity we have to get in
action mode we have to get to work this
photo shows RJ employees in their
Newsroom listening to police scanners
and detectives closing in on Telus we're
watching and waiting and we wait
and we wait police searched telus's
house among their evidence a mutilated
sun hat sneakers with blood stains and
his DNA at the murder scene WE Post our
story and it's a hell of a story a
sitting elected official is a person of
interest in the murder of an
investigative journalist in the United
States it's unbelievable five days after
the murder Telus was arrested
photographer Kevin Cannon got this shot
for his friend Jeff gearman my
preparation and experience allowed me to
get that photo
and I know he'd be proud
almost simultaneously to the time that
the ambulance doors close
I get a phone call from the sheriff and
he says Glenn I wanted you to know that
Robert Tullis is in custody and under
arrest in connection with the murder of
Jeff German
the headline on the paper's front page a
stunning arrest in the death of a
journalist what's a big part of the
motivation here we got to do this right
the way Jeff would have wanted it done
absolutely this is the kind of story
that Jeff you know would have grabbed a
hold of and never let go the RJ's now in
a First Amendment fight police seized
garman's laptop and cell phones as
evidenced the paper wants to deny them
access it's another part of Jeff
gearman's Legacy here but hardly the
only one we will have a hole in our
Newsroom I don't think our city will
ever grasp how much he did but our
Newsroom will
oh boy Mark wow your story gives me
goosebumps and chills I mean it must be
surreal for his colleagues to
immediately when they heard about his
death have a suspect in mind and then
actively work to make sure that that
suspect is arrested it's I've never
heard of a story like this to be honest
with you
yeah the best of the paper is researched
it had never happened before Gail were a
sitting public official had murdered uh
or allegedly murdered a journalist and
and you're right there there are a
couple of different things going on here
they're they're investigating the story
and yet they're they're also grieving
the loss of their colleague and there
was also something else Gail which was a
Fear Factor at first what they didn't
realize who this who even the suspect
was all they knew is that one of their
colleagues had been murdered and so they
also wanted whether they were potential
targets so one of the reporters was
telling me that every time she opened
the garage door she of her house she
half expected to see a suspect did it so
um anyway it's it's the paper really did
some remarkable work given what they
were also all going through emotionally
yeah well the paper is a long Legacy of
powerful investigatory work and I'm sure
they're not going to be shrinking from
that Duty going forward uh even in the
face of this terrible tragedy yeah so
clear what Jeff meant to them too yeah
because even as tragic as this is he's
still leading the way exactly for sure
all right Mark thank you so much